since he was a kid
Michael gammas wanted to work on cars
just like his dad and his grandfather he
fixed up and sold his first used car
when he was fourteen it felt really good
to build something up and sell it for a
profit the fact that I was able to do
something like that
which was kind of like ok you know I
know what I'm doing this is what I want
to do but gammas his teachers
conditioned him to believe that he
needed to go to college they kind of
just thought that my dream of being a
mechanic was kind of like one of those
childhood dreams they kind of thought
that a mechanic wasn't a successful job
that was kind of like a lower-class job
so we enrolled at UC Irvine with a plan
to major in mechanical engineering
during his sophomore year gammas dropped
out because he realized he wasn't on the
path he wanted so I talked to my
counselors like to my directors I even
talked to like the president of UC
Irvine I finally every single person I
could to simply want to stay at UC
Irvine and do what I wanted to do at the
end of the day was kind of like you
shouldn't you don't belong here
public colleges and universities should
be tuition free and debt free for all
Americans make college universally
available with free tuition and fees
several Democratic presidential
candidates have promised that if elected
they'll make public college tuition free
and wipe clear federal student loan debt
which in the u.s. tops of 1.5 trillion
dollars they say that making college
universal will lead to higher
productivity and more economic
opportunity for people like Michael
gammas if you make College free then
there's gonna be so many bas floating
around that if you want to get a better
job then you're gonna need to go and get
some Supplemental degree Bryan Caplan is
an economist at George Mason University
who's skeptical that professors like him
have much to offer most students his
book is called the case against
education we're spending too much time
and money on education because most of
what you learn in school you will never
use after the final exam we like to
pretend otherwise but really if you just
calmly compare what we're studying to
what we really do the connection is
shockingly weak Kaplan says that most
people attend college is a way to signal
to prospective employers that they're
reasonably intelligent conscientious
conformist the signaling story is mostly
that our society says that you're
supposed to graduate and if you're
supposed to graduate the failure to
graduate signals nonconformity so if you
want people to treat you well you better
go and conform if you remember what it's
like to be a student you have to jump
through an endless series of seemingly
meaningless arbitrary unfair hoops and
people that are willing to just bite
their tongues and suffer through it are
the ones who are also going to the to be
good at doing that once they get a job
Kaplan's case rests partly on the
so-called sheepskin effect named for the
sheepskin upon which diplomas were once
printed studies of college graduates
earnings reveal that the salary increase
for completing the final year of college
is on average more than double that of
completing all three of the previous
years implying
it's the fortitude to obtain the degree
not the knowledge gained that explains
the boost in compensation the human
capital of you says that basically all
of what's going on in schools they are
pouring useful skills into you they are
preparing you for whatever job it is
that you are going to get what I'm
saying is that the main payoff you're
getting from school is that you're
getting certified you're getting stamped
getting what you need to convince
employers that you are a good bet we are
helping our individual participants
build a very strong signal for
themselves as opposed to relying on you
know a third party large institution
praxis combines a professional bootcamp
with a cameron's source B is the CEO of
praxis a professional training program
trying to offer an alternative to
four-year university the way I would
describe our curriculum development
process now is everything is market
driven we're constantly learning what
hiring managers need to see in order to
feel confident that they should hire any
individual participant they're really
good about shifting you from the mindset
of you're doing this for a grade or
you're doing this to get approval like
they put all of the weight on you like
what is your definition of success Lea
Wilczewski enrolled in practices one
year
program focusing on communication
marketing and other jobs it costs
$12,000 but included a six-month paid
apprenticeship worth $16,000 meaning
she'll finish the program $4,000 in the
black well she'll ski is working at
impossible foods the Bay Area company
that sells a meatless hamburger I feel
as if being in practice and being able
to nail a job that typically requires
four years of school if not more and
knowing that there's a whole line of
people who applied for the same job and
being able to nail that at only
twenty-one and without that business
college degree it's like okay with that
knowledge what else can I do after
Michael gammas dropped out of UC Irvine
he enrolled in an auto mechanic trade
school while also working a job at Pep
Boys then he applied for and received a
twelve thousand four hundred dollar
scholarship from micro Works which looks
for two qualities from applicants who
were looking to enter the skilled trades
the willingness to learn a useful skill
and the willingness to work your ass off
combined we think that is something that
ought to be affirmatively rewarded from
there he entered a three-month training
program with BMW and the day after
finishing began his job as a high level
technician at BMW of Beverly Hills I get
excited to go to work because it's
something that I really like to do so I
feel like a lot of people they get
surprised when I tell them the amount of
money that a mechanic or a technician
can make at a dealership they're like
really you guys make that much money
alright yeah so I feel like there's
always this idea that if you don't go to
college you don't get a degree you won't
make a lot of money I think that's wrong
it's kind of where you put yourself even
though it's possible to acquire the
necessary skills to make a good living
without attending college enrollment at
four-year universities has stayed steady
for the past ten years
Kaplan remains skeptical that it will
decline anytime soon so I think things
are gonna stay about the way they are
when you have that kind of free money
coming from people that are not actually
paying out of their own pockets that
tends to freeze the world the of in
place maybe maybe not college has a play
for you know the average student going
forward but I think what's most
important is that people are just
starting to question and starting to
think more critically of what I'd like
to see Moses for young people to have
more access to early professional
opportunity because I think gaining that
early experience is the best way to
learn what you do and and do not want to
pursue as for with shale ski and gammas
she has two more months left in her
apprenticeship and hopes that impossible
foods will keep her on in the sales
department and gammas hopes that working
for BMW is a first step towards
eventually owning his own shop one day
you will see me in my shop like and that
I know how yeah whatever Mike no you
really will and the day that I invite
you to my shop then you'll see
[Music]